let's go next to um
let's go to enoch from pittsburgh
you're on the air hello
hi uh first of all uh thank you for uh
having me
pleasure um so i i i just have a
question
about the congress vote that's coming up
in
uh i believe it's january 6th yes yeah
uh so this is partially of my ignorance
because i'm still
a little like new to the politics and
how all of this work i'm honestly
you know just learning about the uh
congress vote to
um certify the electoral college
um and i i know it has been reported
that
several senators and uh congressmen were
planning to
vote against the electoral college votes
and i'm just wondering if you think that
it's still possible
uh for uh trump and you know his uh
supporters
um in within the congress to try to uh
steal the election by
uh voting against the elect uh electoral
college uh results
no i don't think so um back in the year
remember that the role of the vice
president
is simply to count the votes not to
decide whether votes are valid or
anything like that
so i do expect that there will be
republican members of the house and
maybe even the senate who
when certain votes are counted will
stand up and present an objection
democrats tried this in the year 2000
when the entire presidential election
between al gore and george w
bush depended on florida democrats stood
up and objected to the counting of the
florida
electoral votes and they were able to do
nothing to stop it
in this case it doesn't even come down
to one state it comes down to multiple
states
so i expect objections i don't expect
them to have any impact
thank you so much yeah i was just asking
because i guess the way i understood it
was
uh if they'd uh vote uh against uh those
votes that uh i guess they need to vote
again but i guess that was my
uh understanding of the topic yeah i
don't think
i don't think it's going to happen i
appreciate the call thank you very much
uh i don't i don't expect that to happen
but we'll be covering it live on january
6th that's for sure
all right i'm sorry i wasn't able to
talk to more folks today but we will
take calls again
in 2021 quick break some audience
questions coming up after this short
break